blue City crackdowns on migrant buses
not working as busloads of illegal
migrants are now being dropped off in
Illinois and the New Jersey suburbs
outside of New York City just to use
mass transit to get into Chicago and to
Manhattan our next guest is demanding
answers about more migrants arriving in
New Jersey Congressman there uh
Republican Jeff Andrew joins us right
now uh Congressman good morning to you
good morning so they found a a loophole
the people behind the buses because the
mayor said you got to coordinate with us
if you're going to bring people in and
they said you know what we don't have to
we're gonna drop him across in Jeff Van
Drew state of New
Jersey well let me tell you I mean
everybody's concerned about this
Americans and of course new jerseyans
are tired of illegal immigration and I
say to the people that are watching and
listening to your show right now every
single state in the Union should be
concerned concerned about it number one
number two don't declare yourself a
sanctuary city or a sanctuary State and
say that this is okay unfortunately New
York City did that unfortunately the
governor of the state of New Jersey Phil
Murphy said we were a sanctuary state
that means that you will not cooperate
with ice that you will not cooperate to
get them back to the country of country
of origin that you'll give them all
kinds of help to go to college uh help
as far as domicile and residency help in
trans portation in any way possible we
don't need to do this uh the House of
Representatives has a great piece of
legislation it passed the house that's
sitting in the Senate that would tighten
up the borders the answer isn't more
money into helping these people get
processed and get across the answer is
to tighten up our borders and not allow
illegal activity and you know what I'm
worried for New Jersey because a number
of them did go into New Jersey number
one we can't find out how many and
secondly remember it was only a few
months ago that a plan got leaked out
from Homeland Security thank God
somebody did and they were thinking of
putting up to
60,000 illegals in Atlantic City Airport
in a town of only 35,000 people uh it's
unbelievable this is just the wrong
thing to do it's bad for the country
it's bad for New Jersey certainly bad
for New York well the reason they're
dropping them off in New Jersey and also
there was a bus flowed apparently 60 Mi
uh shy of Chicago
there at a gas station in Illinois as
well the reason they're not coming going
into New York is because the mayor said
last Wednesday executive order you got
to coordinate with us and so they've
started dropping them off at different
train stations in New Jersey and then
the migrants get on the trains and come
into New York but to your point they
don't necessarily have to come into New
York City where I'm sitting right now
and in fact in in our state we both live
in New Jersey in New Jersey I was
talking to somebody yesterday to about
this in New Jersey you do not need a
social security number a card to get a
driver's license so why not stay in New
Jersey absolutely again we have policies
in New Jersey due to this governor and
the Democratic majority that are unkind
to the working people and the citizens
of New Jersey that pay taxes and are
very kind to those that would break the
law and what do they expect of course
the buses are trying to get around the
new regulations the new you know
enforcement that supposedly New York
City was going to have because they're
used to breaking the law it is against
the law to bring people illegally into
the United States of America so if
you're going to break the law once why
not break it a second time this is a
real worry we've got to stop this we've
got to button up the Border we've done
you know legislation as I said in the
House of Representatives that would
finish building the wall because it does
work would not allow uh processing of
these illegals wouldn't allow Catch and
Release would send them back immediately
to the country of origin if they got
through um we have the stay in Mexico
policy and a number of other hire more
enforcement actually right there at the
Border in the form of border patrol we
can do this Steve this isn't complicated
this is easy to do it's not rocket
science it's called enforcing the law
and obeying the laws of the United
States of America Joe Biden could turn
off the flow with a pen and a paper in
10 seconds but he chooses not to all
right uh don't want to Congressman
vandrew thank you very much for joining
us today and happy New Year sir happy
New Year right back to you all right I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kil and I'm Angley
airheart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis